akio iden in den power ihn bedrohen die
erde der meteor storm enthält
potenzieller töten
die laut forscherinnen und forschern in
der lage sind ganze kontinente zu
zerstören ende des jahres passieren wir
wieder die erde bringen sie dann einen
trost bringen brocken mit jetzt endlich
zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
der erlebt mich ja meistens als relativ
ruhigen zeitgenossen wer nicht unbedingt
in panik verfällt wenn er wieder
irgendwelche hier aufs botschaften
verbreitet warum war nicht brennt nicht
und oft ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
ein bestimmtes ereignis dann wirklich
sehr bald stattfindet sehr gering bei
dem möglichen einschlag eines
asteroiden ist das allerdings nicht der
fall die wahrscheinlichkeit ist sogar
ziemlich hoch wissenschaftler
wissenschafterinnen warnen vor solchen
gefährlichen asteroiden und solch
katastrophale einschläge passieren
ständig auf der erde
wie bitte nicht mitbekommen ja wir haben
glück denn weite teile der erde sind
unbewohnt und niemand bekommt es mit
2014 haben wir darüber berichtet die
erde steht sogar unter einem ständigen
bombardement durch gefährliche
asteroiden bis 2014 wurde davon
ausgegangen dass zum beispiel der story
von tscheljabinsk eine sehr seltene
ausnahme und außerdem nicht so
gefährlich gewesen sein
das ist aber ein trugschluss der
asteroid derzeit aufgrund seines
einschlag winkel fast komplett verglüht
ist hätte mit einem anderen winkel eine
großstadt komplett verglichen mit der
hiroshima bombe hatte er die 20 bis 40
fahrer sprengkraft entsprechend dmd
waren es 600 kilo die atombombe über
hiroshima abgeworfen wurde hatte eine
sprengkraft entsprechend 15 kilotonnen
tnt deutlich weniger ein noch größeres
exemplar 2013 wer nicht an der erde
vorbeigeflogen 2012 wird sind für
unterhalt der geostationären satelliten
durch 2014 wurde dann auch eine studie
veröffentlicht die alle verblüffte in
den letzten 13 jahren waren bis dahin 26
ab so eden auf der erde eingeschlagen
und nur einer dieser anschläge wurde
vorher gesagt wir haben also nicht die
geringste ahnung was so alles auf die
erde zu fliegt es ist also dringend
nötig das umfeld der erde näher zu
untersuchen und das haben forscher und
forscherinnen von der tschechischen
akademie der wissenschaften jetzt gesagt
die haben die tauben untersucht und sind
auch wirklich ziemlich beunruhigendes
gestoßen dafür haben wir den
meteoritenschauer der traurigen der 2015
auf der erde niederging näher
untersucht und die größen der
meteoriten untersucht 144 sternschnuppen
und ihre größe haben wir analysiert
und haben dabei nicht nur eine neue
untergruppe der traurigen entdeckt
sondern auch festgestellt dass zwei
größere aktionen dazu gehören 15
ticks 24 und 2005 ua heißen sie dass er
weg ist noch nichts beunruhigendes
allerdings konnten wir aus dieser neuen
gruppe in verbindung mit den
dazugehörigen aktiven hochrechnen was
sonst noch so alles in den theorien
potenziell enthalten ist und das ist gar
nicht beruhigend weil wir leider wissen
was die 1000 regelmäßig die erde
treffen sie gehen davon aus dass der
meteoriten storm gefährliche extrem
zerstörerische abdullah ibn handy
fordern der theoretische untersuchung
und beobachtung der neuen gruppe zitat
ein besseres verstehen dieser realen
quelle von potenziell zerstörerischen
objekten die groß genug sind
signifikant der regionale und selbst
kontinentale zerstörungen auf der erde
zu verursachen ist eine aufgabe von
immenser wichtigkeit
es ist wohl eine der wichtigsten
aufgaben der menschen solche aktuell
befinden uns uns auf die zerstörung
vorzubereiten bevor sie hier auf der
erde einschlagen
bisher hatten wir riesiges glück aber
das kann sich ändern ehemaliger von
außen um den space shuttle piloten
wollen aktuell jeden finden die
zumindest städte länder und kontinente
zerstören können damit sie frühzeitig
erkannt werden will ihre organisation
basics nach 12 ein privat finanzierten
satelliten in den weltraum schicken der
die aktien mit einer wärmebildkamera
findet bisher scheint das projekt aber
nie so recht vom fleck gekommen
ich bin mal gespannt was die
organisation am 30 juni zu vermelden hat
dann ist nämlich der welt ab für jeden
tag den bisher zwölf dieses jahr für
noch mehr öffentlichkeitsarbeit nutzen
will um vor einem potenziellen ab für
ihn ein schlag zu warten wir werden hier
natürlich darüber berichten damit er
nichts verpasst druck mehr hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesse ich den
auf die glocke ja hier geht weiter mit
dem video aktionen bedrohen die erde wo
ich noch ein bisschen mehr über die
bedrohungslage berichte wenn es euch
interessiert da draufklicken ansonsten
bis dann bleib dran